in today's cyber safe parent we delve
into the cyber risk of cryptocurrency
and how to navigate it so it is less
risk and more reward
cryptocurrency is booming it's
essentially a virtual asset you know
meaning that it's it's based off of you
know the blockchain and a specific set
of numbers in a specific order with a
specific cash value but this widespread
popularity has also led to a rise in
crypto cyber risk there's a lot of very
high risks associated with
cryptocurrency you know unlike banking
institutions there's no fdic insurance
on crypto funds how to regulate
cryptocurrencies is being figured out
there's no third party watchdog the
safety of it really depends on who's
holding the cryptocurrency cyber
criminals can essentially crash a party
that's still being planned crypto cyber
risk involves phishing malware hack
trading platforms and laundered money
one of the primary uses for
cryptocurrency is by criminal elements
to be able to move those funds quickly
without any detection by investigative
entities
when war breaks out cryptocurrency is
relied on to avoid sanctions and move
money whenever there's war or any type
of a major conflict
the value of cryptocurrency generally
spikes during those conflicts there are
upsides to cryptocurrency if you want it
to be you know more private and be able
to do quick transactions you know
without banking regulators or the
federal government or somebody else
being involved
i would say it can be a useful tool to
capitalize on this new opportunity and
stay cyber safe look to the bigger
outfits if it's not a big name
cryptocurrency exchange i would stay
away from it and steer clear of the
scammer who wants to buy crypto for you
there's a lot of scams out there there's
a lot of people who say oh you know go
through me and i'll buy you bitcoin or
ethereum or whatever it is but a lot of
those people are scammers it's smoke and
mirrors they might even create a wallet
or an account that you can log into to
be able to see your money
then when it comes time to go to pull
your money out now they're trying to
charge you a fee to pull your money out
and then once you give them even more of
your hard-earned cash they disappear for
cryptocurrency investors buckle up it
can fluctuate wildly from day to day
there is some some opportunities there
for some massive gains but what most
people don't talk about is the massive
losses that happen as well